Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
video marvel just released a bunch of new details
benedict cumberbatch dropped a clip talking about
the movie so we'll break it all down because it
sounds like they're making a bunch of changes to
the story so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos we'll
start learning more about the movie as we get
ready for spiderman no way home because doctor
strange 2 is the next movie right after that
so all the craziness you see doctor strange
and spider-man causing with the main mcu universe
blending all these different realities with doctor
strange's spell that's also going to set the
stage for what's happening during doctor strange 2
because the title is literally multiverse of
madness but recently you probably saw the news
marvel announced that they were delaying all the
marvel phase 4 movies after spider-man no way home
by a couple months kevin feige talked about it
i did a big video for it it was at the eternals
premiere i'll play the clip in a second but right
after that more recently benedict cumberbatch
explained what was actually going on with doctor
strange 2 and now it all makes a little more sense
how they're changing the story here's the clip
of kevin feige talking about them moving all
the movies around and then ben into cover match
talking about what's happening with doctor strange
2 production shifts and changes and because we
have so many uh slots we can just shift slots
so we're not so all the marvel slots are the
same we're just shifting the movies coming out
and uh and yes strange has moved
six weeks so instead of there being
uh three months between marvel movies there'll
be five months between marvel movies and i think
that we can all handle that we have to ask
about doctor strange 2 uh what can you tell
us about the film uh very excited sam romy's at
the helm so expect extraordinary things and uh
yeah we're in the middle of making it even
better we've got some reshoots coming up in
november and december and then it comes out in
may and i guess you'll have to wait until then
so kevin feige just explains they're shifting all
the movies by one slot but all the actual dates
are still the same so instead of doctor strange
two coming out in march after the batman movie now
it's coming out in may when they were originally
releasing thor love and thunder now thor love and
thunder is coming out in the summer so on and so
forth but he says it's all because of production
issues and they just need more time to work
that out and in that benedict cumberbatch clip
he confirms that they're doing extensive reshoots
on doctor strange 2 during november and december
2 months of re-shoots if you're not familiar with
how movies get made that's a lot of reshoots and
that's on top of another month of reshoots that
they just got done doing for doctor strange 2
back in september you may remember elizabeth olsen
and her makeup team posted this photo to announce
that they had wrapped all the reshoots for
scarlet witch back in september so now benedict
cumberbatch is saying they need even more reshoots
for another two months and what that means is that
they're making hardcore changes on the story
and all the characters typically reshoots on big
movies like this only last for a couple weeks to
like a month or so when they do more than that is
because they decided to completely change what's
going on with big parts of the movie outside of
major action scenes and the current report is
that part of what they're wanting to change
now is scarlet witch's story during the movie and
there are all these rumors about them adding more
alternate universe versions of characters more
easter eggs more wtf moments and that's on top of
all the rumors about them including a version of
the marvel illuminati team and x-men cameo scene
reports there's been a long-running rumor for the
past year that they're going to debut a version
of marvel's illuminati team in the movie in some
way either they come together for the first time
or we see an alternate universe version of the
team but the illuminati in the comics are this
covert think tank team originally consisting of
mr fantastic from the fantastic four iron man from
the avengers professor x doctor strange black bolt
of the inhumans in namor some of those characters
we have in the mcu some of them we don't and some
of them just died recently press f to pay respects
for iron man but the whole idea with the team
is that they deal with the highest level threats
and they make a lot of questionable choices but
ones that they feel like are necessary as the
name implies illuminati is kind of a loaded term
usually when you talk about the illuminati it's in
a bad context i just did a video about the report
marvel is working on a new hulk movie that's based
on world war hulk well that came after planet hulk
the illuminati were the ones that were responsible
for sending hulk into outer space where he wound
up on sakhar setting the events for planet hulk
and world war hulk i did a video a while ago about
all the reports about a version of professor x
showing up in the movie too either james mcavoy
or patrick stewart there was a report that someone
from the fox x-men movies would be facing scarlet
witch during the movie like they would have this
big fight and who would be powerful enough to
face her so that's why everyone was talking about
a version of professor x they're supposed to be
introducing a version of neymar and black panther
too but i don't think that they have plans to do
black bolt or the inhumans anytime soon in the mcu
so if we do see a version of the illuminati in the
mcu during the film they'd have to have a slightly
different roster all the reports about them using
some of these reshoots to change scarlet witch's
storyline have more to do with making her seem
like less of a psychopathic killer just tearing
through everyone like wet tissue paper with her
chaos magic you may remember all the clips from
elizabeth olsen earlier this year when they
were still filming the movie when she talked
about them using her character in doctor strange
2 in a completely different way than what we saw
from her in Wandavision like she said it was a
completely different utilization of the character
as in she would wind up being one of the secret
villains of the movie and if she is that powerful
during Wandavision when she finally sort of
figures out her chaos magic at least a little bit
you have to assume she's going to be off the
chain during doctor strange 2. there's a lot of
things that kevin feige the Wandavision showrunner
elizabeth olsen said about her character after the
Wandavision finale including some deleted scenes
for context that kind of soft confirmed this
everyone posted all these memes about how she's
basically kind of a villain because she trapped
them all there against their will elizabeth olsen
said that they wanted her to come off as kind of
villainous at the end of the series like maybe
not an outright villain but she's definitely
on the wrong side of the law at the end of the
Wandavision series if it wasn't clear they spent
the second half of the Wandavision episodes up to
the finale trying to frame things more as wanda
dealing with her trauma and not wanting to hurt
everyone but also not really understanding how
her chaos magic powers worked how she was really
being manipulated by tyler heyward sword agatha
harkness just kind of gaslighting her so that she
would break and use her chaos magic so they could
steal it so at the end of the day it wasn't so
much about her being a villain it was more about
her being manipulated by other more villainous
people so it sounds like they kind of want to
keep that same vibe during doctor strange 2 and
whatever they filmed before it just didn't make
that very clear the current rumor right now is
that the real villain of the movie will actually
be the schumacherth and it will be manipulating
scarlet witch who thinks she's trying to rescue
her children billy and tommy from another universe
another dimension when i posted my Wandavision
finale video that was a lot of people's first
guest too is that she was being manipulated
in this scene like those aren't really her
children somebody else is trying to mess with her
there are a couple extra dimensional villains
connected to the darkhold in the mcu but shuma
gorath seems like the leading theory right
now his mo in the comics is to take control
of other characters mentally and use them to
try and break back into the main mcu dimension
i've already done a longer video on his character
inside the mcu so i'll add a link for that down
in the description if you want to learn more
about how the shuma gorath fits into all this
you may have also seen all the reports a little
while ago too about tom hiddleston supposedly
coming back as a loki for the movie in some way
they didn't say what he'd be doing in the movie
but it would be our loki that we just got done
watching during the loki series like they're
not gonna bring infinity war loki back to life for
this in side note he also just did a recent comic
con event with sylvie and kang and he said the
first scene of loki season two the opening scene
will start with this moment here that we saw
at the end of the finale when he comes running
into that alternate timeline version of the tva
and sees that everything has changed in the real
mcu king the conqueror has taken over the tva and
nobody remembers who he is so season two episode
one he'll be running and yelling at mobius about
he who remains king just like this and i think
the idea is that those episodes will be released
during 2023 you may have seen there's a big disney
plus day comic con event in a couple weeks with
a bunch of trailers and previews they're going to
be releasing we'll learn more about all the marvel
disney plush shows that are coming up during that
so we'll do trailer videos for everything that
they release make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss that stuff in
early theory just connecting doctor strange to to
spiderman no way home doctor strange and spiderman
are already messing with the multiverse combining
aspects of different realities and timelines
to change the main mcu universe is a slightly
different version of what wanda was doing inside
the hex wanda was kind of re-skinning everyone and
just sort of mentally controlling everyone
fitting them into her little scenario what
doctor strange is doing is literally combining
different elements from alternate universes
so early theory at the end of spider-man no
way home they will probably not wind up fixing
everything and some of the other consequences
in addition to all the multiverse sinister six
characters showing up is that on top of all this
craziness scarlet witch uses the darkhold in her
chaos magic to start doing something similar
in an attempt to bring her children back and
it turns into a way way worse version of what
you see happening during spider-man no way home
imagine a way worse version of this with scarlet
witch in her chaos magic but at the end of the day
i think the whole idea with these doctor strange
2 ratios is they're trying to make it way crazier
but still have it all make sense and whatever it
is that they did before it just doesn't all quite
make sense enough marvel's dropping the eternals
movie really soon so i'll be posting my full
post credit scene video for easter egg breakdown
videos for the movie as soon as it does come out
everywhere let me know in the comments if you have
any big questions or any special bonus videos that
you guys want me to do everyone click here for
my new spider-man no way home trailer video for
the new doctor strange scenes they release and
click here for my marvel eternals movie review
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!